tu es le meilleur des meilleurs mais le
jour le plus fier de ma vie a été quand tu es
devenu légitime tu as fondé une famille et
tu es sorti de la vie attendons que
Chris rentre à la maison c'est mon frère ce qui s'est passé
et moi qui dirige quelque chose et j'ai
jeté le paquet  non j'ai arrêté de
courir en te promettant que tu vas rester en dehors
de ça tu vas me tuer
d'entre vous, comment se fait-il que vous demandiez à votre
femme ou à votre enfant que le repu aille au
pistolet avez-vous déjà mentionné ma femme et mes enfants à
nouveau vous l'avez fait vous savez ce retour à la
maison si vous ne payez pas vous connaissez les routes à
droite je dois essayer de  réparez ça croyez-moi je
sais ce que je fais qu'est-ce que nous gérons
15 millions de dollars sur quatre piles c'est
comme la taille d'une mini cooper où tu
vas le cacher où est la foi j'ai perdu
mes galons maintenant je dois recommencer à
zéro avez-vous  jamais été reconnu coupable d'
espionnage sédition
trahison avec le  tu diriges quelque chose sur mon
bateau bon tu prends de l'argent pour gagner de l'
argent yay non non ce n'est pas bueno dis
au revoir à ta femme et viens je
viens pour toi nous allons faire la guerre
là nous allons ouvrir le conteneur
où est mon argent  dites-lui de ne pas le jeter
à l'eau, vous ne trouverez jamais que l'
argent
appuie sur la gâchette